this dude is British but since we had
the cast of Downton Abbey on the show
sip it and fill it if you've had the
greatest time maybe we'd play a little
British themed game called Brit or
counterfeit all right so I have a stack
of celebrities right here and I'm gonna
try and see if I can guess if they are
British and real-life or not so it's
probably easy for other people but
probably definitely not me
Oh Christian Bale he's American
so he's not American what this dude is
British he is the greatest American
accent I've ever what witness you speak
British
or Boyd one or whatever whatever what
okay you're incredible mr. Bale what
that was insane
I'm really gonna suck at this game it's
fine oh yeah no Cate Blanchett trying to
trick me here you're trying to throw me
not British Australian right I think I
know this one Charlie's thrown I think
she's South African she is South African
apparently I only care about where the
women are from like winner isla Fisher
she's she's American right where's she
from Australia Scottish and Australian
that's why she's hot that's cool that's
a hot little mixture that's awesome oh
this is her husband Sacha Baron Cohen no
I don't know where he's from he's not
British is he British he's British
always British well he's British guys
duh Oh see I'm sorry do you mean Sir
Anthony Hopkins why yes he is British
he's a Brit he's been knighted it's real
Anna Paquin she's American No
where's she from New Zealand I knew I
liked her I Love New Zealand Lupita
Nyong'o okay she is super beautiful I'm
gonna say British because she's cool not
British okay
Mexican and Kenyan whoa dropping the mic
that's a cool mixture I love this game
Audrey Hepburn Steve I want to say
American but I think she's British she's
British right Audrey Hepburn thinking
she's Britain Katharine Hepburn's
British right dude come on there are two
famous women with the last name Hepburn
and they're not related that's not like
Smith y'all Oh Naomi Watts she's
Australian yes yes she is me Naomi Watts
grew up in Australia but she grew up in
Australia hmm Oh Russell Crowe he's
Australian crikey
he's up oh that's not the same they
don't like that oh they don't like when
he makes the New Zealand's in Australia
Trevor Noah if you thought that [ __ ]
South Africa I love Trevor Noah
Andrew Garfield American no
British Keri Russell American yeah turn
throw me I got this oh my god Felicity
Kiefer Sutherland's such a red Oh young
guns one of the best films of all time
go ahead I'm gonna go ahead and say I
want to say American but I know
somebody's gonna be like no he's British
and I just feel like I'm gonna say
British British okay but he's so
American to me I pretty much sucked at
that it's fine
I mean I'm kind of I feel like I was
tricked people I feel like people have
like dual citizenships going on I will
say wait the one that tricked me the
most was Lupita that's cool any Mexican
I like it she's beautiful I think I did
like mmm I'm not an actress so I don't
have to know so like that
not that all actresses happiness of like
I mean who Nina no what you want to know
okay bye
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going